[MUSIC]
Eh,
that's right, you
suddenly came to see
me and I'm on a big move No, no, my opponent is a child.
I'm Kleis. I'm Arlan
Steart. Do you have something to talk about?
Even if
I invite you, you'll be turned down because I have a promise to you Even when we're together, all I
talk
about is
you.  doing
is unattractive,
so this is the first time I've been ridiculed to my face head buggy I
'm not sure if I'm prepared or not enough Rice
's rants are taken as o 0's challenge Done
painting
ah ah ah
[music]
Edazeki  In the climbing showdown, Alan said he would let the woman decide how to win,
so this was the only thing I could think
of that I was good at.
Standing up, pufferfish Yabe recognizes the celebration and the mother's poem For Mr. k's sake, let's quickly
match it up
Shall we start?
First place 4
haa
ah ah ah
[music]
hey caboose